right the equation of the function f of
X graphed below so we have this clearly
periodic function so immediately you
might say well this is either going to
be a sine function or cosine function
but its midline and its amplitude are
not just the plain vanilla sine or
cosine function and we can see that
right over here the midline is halfway
between the maximum point and the
minimum point the maximum point right
over here it hits a value of y equals
one at the minimum points it hits a
value of y is equal to negative five so
halfway between those want the average
of 1 and negative 5 1 plus negative 5 is
negative 4 divided by 2 is negative 2 so
this right over here is the midline so
this thing is clearly so this is y is
equal to negative 2 this is y is equal
to negative 2 so it's clearly clearly
shifted down so it's we're going to have
so I'll actually I'll talk in a second
about what type of an expression it
might be but now also let's think about
its amplitude its amplitude that's how
far it might get away from the midline
we see here it went 3 above the midline
going from negative 2 to 1 and went 3
above the midline at the maximum point
and it can also go 3 below the midline
at the minimum point so this thing
clearly has an amplitude of 3 so
amplitude amplitude of 3 so immediately
we can say well look this is going to
have a form something like f of X is
equal to the amplitude 3 3 it we haven't
figured out yet whether we this is going
to be a cosine function or a sine
function so I'll write cosine first
cosine maybe some coefficient times X
plus the midline the midline we already
figured out was minus 2 or negative 2 so
it could take that form or it could take
f of X is equal to is equal to 3 times
it could be sine of X or sine of some
coefficient times X sine of KX minus 2
plus the midline so minus 2 so how do we
figure out which of these are well let's
just think about the behavior of this
function when X is equal to 0
when X is equal to 0 if this is KX then
the input into this into the cosine is
going to be 0 cosine of 0 is 1
whether you're talk about degrees or
radians cosine of 0 is 1 while sine of 0
so if x is 0 K times 0 is going to be 0
sine of 0 is 0 so what's this thing
doing when X is equal to 0 well when X
is equal to 0 we are at the midline if
we're at the midline that means that all
of this stuff right over here evaluated
to 0 so since when x equals 0 all of
this stuff evaluated is 0 we can rule
out the cosine function when x equals 0
here this stuff doesn't evaluate to 0 so
we can rule out this one right over
there and so we are left with this and
we just really need to figure out what
is what is this what could be what could
this constant actually be and to think
about that let's look at the period of
this of this function so to go from to
go from and we could we could let's see
if we went from this point where we
intersect the midline we go this point
to intersect the midline and we have a
positive slope the next point that we do
that is right over here so our period is
8 our period is 8 so what coefficient
could we have here to make a period make
the period of this thing be equal to 8
well let's just remind ourselves what
the period of sine of X is so the period
of sine of X so I'll write period right
over here is 2 pi 2 pi you increase your
angle by 2 pi radians or decrease it
you're back at the same point on the
unit circle so what would be the period
of sine of KX well now your X your input
is increasing K times faster so you're
going to get to the same point K times
faster so your period is going to be is
going to be 1 K as as long so now your
period is going to be 2 pi over K notice
you're increasing your argument as x
increases your argument into the sine
function is increasing K times as fast
you're multiplying it by K so your
period is going to be short is going to
take you less distance
to get for the whole argument for to get
to the same point on the unit circle so
let's think about it this way
now so if we wanted to say two pi over K
is equal to 8 so if 2 PI over K is equal
to 8 well what is our K well we could
take the reciprocal of both sides we get
K over 2 pi is equal to 1 over 8
multiply both sides by 2 pi and we get
we get K is equal to let's see this is 1
this is 4 K is equal to PI over 4 and we
are done and you can verify that by
trying out some of these points right
over here that this function is equal to
3 sine of PI over 4 X minus 2